All right, so what
we're going to do today
is continue our
discussion of modularity
and how you hook software
modules up together.
And what we did
the last time was
talked about how you share data
between programs between users.
And we went to the design
of the UNIX file system,
or at least a particular
aspect of the UNIX file system
where we talked about how
we built a file system out
of layers and layers.
And each layer was essentially
doing name resolution in order
for us to take a UNIX
path name and eventually
get the data blocks
corresponding
to the data in that file.
What we're going to do today is
to move away a little bit from
the memory abstraction, which
is what we spend our time
on the last time, and start
talking about the second
abstraction -- the
interpreter abstraction.
And we're going to do that
in the context of software
libraries, and
basically understand
how software libraries
are put together,
and how you can build
large software programs out
of individual software modules
that get hooked together.
So that's the plan for today.
And in addition to seeing
the actual mechanism for how
you take all these modules
in the form of libraries
and other software pieces,
hook them up together,
what we are really
going to focus on
is the mechanism by which these
different modules actually
run on your computer.
OK, so it's going to involve a
fair amount of mechanism going
down to the lowest
layer until you actually
have something that's a
single, executable file that
runs on your computer.
And then what we're
going to do is
to step back and think
about the kind of modularity
that we will have gotten
from this approach.
And that's the
kind of modularity
that we're going to
call soft modularity.
So, that's the plan for today.
And you'll see why this
is called soft modularity.
And it has to do with the way
in which propagation of faults
occurs and in particular
the kind of modularity
at the libraries that we
are going to discuss today
has the property that a problem
in one module, for example,
an infinite loop or
a crash in one module
will turn out to affect
the whole program.
And the whole thing will
come crumbling down.
OK, and that's why it's going
to be called soft modularity.
Of course, we don't like
that kind of modularity,
although it is useful
to have soft modularity.
So the next three lectures
after today, we're
going to talk about hardening
the soft modularity using
a variety of
different techniques.
So that's the plan for the
next three to four lectures.
OK, so let's take some examples
to start with of where you end
up using these modules --
these software modules --
to build bigger
software systems.
And the first one
is actually what you
see in programming language.
When you use C or C++ or Java
or Perl or any of these programs
that you're familiar with, you
end up actually building large
programs out of taking
lots of little programs,
usually programmed
in different files,
and running a compiler on it,
and it'll turn out to require
other system software to take
programs that are written
in different modules and
hook them all up together
into a bigger program.
And this is actually
going to be,
we're going to learn today
with examples from C or C++
programming language to find
out how we build C modules
together.
But, by no means
are we restricted
to these programming languages.
In fact, there's a lot
of different examples.
Database systems provide a
great example of modularity.
So if you take a
system like, you
might've heard of
Oracle or Sybase,
or any of IBM's DB2,
all of these things
are fairly complicated
pieces of software.
But what they invariably
allow you to do
is to put in your own software,
your own code, that will run
as part of the database system.
So if you, for
example, come up with,
you know, normally databases
allow you to run queries
on tables of data.
We'll be back after
these messages.
OK, so every database system
allows you to upload modules
into it that run as part
of the database system.
So if you come up with a
different kind of data type,
for example, some geometric
data type on which you asked
whether there is a bunch
of points inside a polygon,
a regular database system
won't actually support that.
But what you can do is
write code for that,
and upload it, and run it as
a module in a database system.
Another example, a common
example these days are Web
servers, particularly
something like Apache --
-- where you can actually
include as part of Apache when
you run it a bunch of different
modules for doing a variety
of new functions that
weren't previously running.
And all of these
different kinds of systems
will turn out to use
essentially variants
of the same basic idea
in terms of solving
the problem of taking these
different modules together
and composing a single, large
program that you can execute
on your computer.
So what we're going to do
today is discuss this method,
this way of doing modularity
in the context of,
a particular example,
it's easiest to do
this with an example.
And then we'll
step back and talk
about the general principles.
So, we're going to focus
on the Linux operating
system running the GNU tools.
And in particular, we're going
to focus on how you do this
in a language like C or C++.
And so, most of you are probably
familiar with some of the tools
that you use to build
programs in GNU and Linux
and we are going to
use a compiler called
GCC that will turn out to use
some other pieces of software
to build modular programs.
So, that's kind of what
we're going to start with.
And the basic approach in terms
of how these modules are going
to be written is if you want to
write a program, you typically
design what you want to
do, design the system,
and then decide on
how you decompose
the functionality of
your system into a bunch
of different modules.
And typically you write one
or more files for each module
and system, and then you need a
way to bring all these modules,
these different files together
to build a bigger program.
And when you run GCC in
particular on a dot O file,
the modules themselves
want to compile a C file.
As you know, you
produce an object file
with a name like file dot O, and
that actually contains in it,
that's an object file
that with some more work
you can arrange to
run on your computer.
And what we're going to
do today is figure out
how when you have a large
number of object files,
and it will also turn out, we'll
talk about something called
a library, which is a
collection of object files put
into a single archive, or how
you can take those object files
and produce an
executable that will run.
So if this works,
let me show you
an example of what we're
going to be talking about.
So I have two little files,
a little trivia program.
I don't know if this is visible.
OK, so all this is
doing is computing
the square of the number.
And it uses here, this is
a very trivial program.
It defines a few
variables, and then just
calls on modular function
called SQR, which isn't actually
in this file.
It's in a separate file.
But one thing you
can do is run GCC-C
which just tells it to
produce the object file,
and there's a program
called object dump which
is a useful program
if you want to see
what's inside your object file.
It's a binary
file, so you're not
going to be able to hack it.
But you could run it with, we've
already reached the bottom,
all right.
OK, so the part to worry
about for the moment
are shown in the
last three lines
that you could see here
starting main, SQR, and printf.
And those are the
three functions
that are being invoked by
the program I showed you.
And you can see,
for SQR and printf,
this object file doesn't
actually know where it is
or where its definition is.
And that's why you
see UND for undefined.
And part of what we're
going to figure out today
is how we can find out where
those other modules are
defined, and hook up all those
different modules together
to build a program
that will actually run
to do what we want it to do.
So the other thing
here is square dot C,
which does the obvious thing of
just multiplying two numbers.
And you could do the same
thing with square dot C.
So I have a little thing called
show object which is just
an alias for object dump.
And you can see here that
there aren't actually
any undefined symbols
or undefined functions
because square, in
turn, didn't invoke
anything that was outside
and defined somewhere else.
And underneath here, you see the
actual disassembled assembler
code for this machine text.
So going back to M
dot O, I just want
to draw your attention
to a couple of things.
Yeah?
Shows up fine on
my screen, I know.
[LAUGHTER] All right, good.
OK, so there's a few sections
to this object file here.
And it's important to
understand a little bit
how an object file is laid out.
It has in it a few different
sections as I mentioned.
One of the sections is
called the text section.
The text section basically
contains the machine code.
I mean, ideally once you hook
all these modules together,
that machine code will actually
just run on your computer.
It also has a section, I
think you can see it up there,
called auto data.
That's the second section that
stands for read only data.
And one of the things I
had here in that program
was something that said
printf with a string inside.
And, that string
is read only data.
I mean, you don't want, the
program doesn't actually
modify it.
And that's the kind of thing
you could see it on the right.
There is a comment there:
the square of something
is something.
And that's an example
of read only data.
And then it has a
section for data
which really corresponds to
the global variables used
in the program.
And for those of you
who remember 6.004,
and if not we'll talk
about this next time.
The look of variables
in your modules
are not actually in
the data section.
They're typically on the stack.
So we're not going to
worry about that for today.
And then there's a
section called a symbol
table which is shown
here, I think, as sym tab
not on the screen.
Let me go back.
So that's the symbol table.
And what this symbol
table shows is
the different global
variables and functions
that are either defined in
the module in this dot O file
or are referenced
by this module.
OK, and for the symbols that
are defined in this module, what
the symbol table tells you
is the address at which you
can find it in the module.
OK, and for the things
that are not defined,
it says it's undefined.
And hopefully once
the compiler sees
all of the different
object files involved,
it can piece together these
different object files
and build a larger
program module.
So when you compile each of
these things in this example, M
dot O and SQR dot
O, you will find
that the object file that's
produced for both files
starts with address zero.
OK, so obviously when you hook
these modules up together,
you can't have both modules
run at address zero.
So one of the things you
need to be able to do
is to take these different
object files together,
and somehow join them so that
the addresses are no longer
colliding with one another.
So that's one problem that we
are going to have to solve.
So that's what we're
going to do today.
So there's basically
three steps that we
are going to talk about today.
The first step is figuring out
all these different symbols.
So when you have SQR or if
you were using square root
in a different program,
printf is another example,
figuring out where the
definitions of these symbols
are, and where the definitions
of the global variables
are in your program.
And that's a step called
symbol resolution.
OK, and the plan is going to be
that each object file is going
to have inside it
a table like here
that shows for the symbols
that have been locally defined,
where in the local
module they are.
I'm going to use the word
module for these dot O files.
And for symbols that are
not in the same dot O file,
it just says it's undefined.
And I need it.
OK, and that's what
the dot O contains.
And, when you take all these
dot O's together and produce
a bigger program, those symbols
are going to be resolved.
And that's the step
called symbol resolution.
The second thing we
have to do before we
get a single big program is to
do something called relocation.
So what relocation
is, is remember
I told you when you compile
a program to a dot O file,
all of the dot O files all have
addresses starting from zero.
You can't run them all
together unless you actually
modify the different addresses.
And any time you see a reference
to a variable in one of the dot
O files, you have to
modify that address
to point to the actual address
at which the instruction would
run or the data
object is present.
And that's called relocation.
And it'll turn out
that the object files
that are produced by the
compiler are what are called
relocatable object files.
Pretty much every object file
these days is relocatable.
But the relocatable
object file allows
you to do this relocation
easily because it
has in it information that
tells whoever is composing
these modules together how to
modify the addresses that are
referenced within each module.
And the third step
once you do all this
and you produce a single
big program that's
ready to execute, is
actually to run the program.
And that's a step called
loading or program loading.
So you create a big
executable file,
and you type it on
the command line.
What happens?
So, those are the three
steps that we are going
to be talking about today.
And the first two steps
typically are called linking.
OK, so most of today
is going to be talking
about how linking works.
And the piece of
software, system software,
that does linking
is called a linker.
And in the GNU-Linux
operating system,
it's a program called LD.
That's the linking program.
And so when you run GCC
to take a bunch of modules
and produce a program out
of it, underneath inside
not visible to you but
underneath, GCC actually
invokes a bunch of
other programs including
LD as one of the
last steps to produce
an actual file that will run.
So the linker takes as
input, object files,
and produces as output a
program that you can run.
And then the loader takes
over and runs the program.
So there are actually
three kinds of object files
that the linker
takes as argument.
The first kind of object file
is a relocatable object file.
OK, actually there's two kinds.
The first kind is a
relocatable object file.
And that's what we're going to
be spending most of our time
on.
The second kind of
object file is something
called a share object file.
We are going to get to this
a little bit at the end.
And the reason we're going
to wait until the end
is that the reason for
a shared object file
is that if you have a program, a
module like printf or some math
library like using
functions like square root,
if you just do linking
the normal way, which
is the easy way we're going to
talk about for most of today,
you will end up with a program
that includes in its text that
includes in the binary
all of the modules
corresponding to all
of the libraries at,
you know, the text corresponds
to the different modules
that you use.
So now, if you have 100
different programs running
on your system, all
of which use printf,
it will turn out that
every program is quite big.
And so, shared object files
allow us to not actually have
to include the text of printf
in every binary that we produce,
but just maintain a pointer
to something that says,
when you need printf, go
and get this, and include it
as part of your program.
So we get to that in the end.
But for the most
part, we are going
to be focusing on relocatable
object files, that is,
object files that are
produced by something like GCC
that I showed you, which include
in it information for modifying
the addresses that are being
referenced inside the module.
And once the linker
takes these as arguments,
what it produces as output,
out comes an executable file.
And these dot O's
don't actually run.
The executable is a thing that's
capable of actually running.
OK, so the first step
we have to talk about
is symbol resolution.
And so the input is a
set of object files.
And the output is
going to be something
that allows LD,
the linker program,
to know which symbol
is located where
in all the different modules.
And if your linking
succeeds, then it
means that every symbol
that's been referenced
by any of the modules that's
on the command line of this LD
program, there are no
undefined symbols remaining.
So that's what symbol
resolution does.
And the input to this is
really it looks something
like you have a bunch of files.
I'm going to call them F1
dot O, F2 dot O, all the way
through FN dot O.
OK, and for those of you
who know what libraries,
don't worry about them now.
We are just going to take
these individual modules,
and we are going to produce
out of it a single program that
includes in it all of
these different modules
such that there are no
unresolved symbols, OK?
So, SQR is one file, and M
dot C contains references
SQR, we want to make it so
the actual program, when
the reference to SQR comes
in, you know where it is.
So, what each file contains
when you do GCC on F1 dot CN,
you get F1 dot O,
it contains in it
already a local symbol table.
And you saw that in the
example I showed you.
And the symbol table has
the following structure.
There's two kinds of data in the
symbol table on a local module.
The first is a set
of icons, D1, that
correspond to global
variables or functions that
are defined in the
module F1 dot C,
and therefore are defined
in the module F1 dot O.
So, this just tells
the linker, you
know, if you see the symbol
being invoked by somebody else,
it's being defined
in this module.
OK, and it contains
in it information
about where in the
local module it
does it so that you know
at what address it's
being defined and so on.
Likewise, you have here
another set of symbols
that you want which
corresponds to things that
are not defined in F1 dot O.
And likewise, for each of these
things you have D2 and U2,
and so on, OK?
So, the way the
particular implementation
of the linker under
GNU-Linux works,
and there are many ways
to implement linkers,
and there are very complicated
linkers, and obviously simple
linkers as well.
The Linux one is
particularly simple
at least in terms of this
way of linking, resolving
all of the symbols here.
You just scan the command
line from left to right
and you start building
up three sets, OK?
So we're going to build up
three sets in this algorithm
when we scan from left to right.
The first set is a set
I'm going to call O.
And the idea in O is going
to be all of object files
that go into the
program, that go
into the output of
the linking step.
In this case, in
the end, it's going
to be pretty straightforward.
It's going to be F1 dot O, union
F2, all the way up to union FN.
It's going to get a
little more complicated
when we talk about libraries.
But for now, it's
a very easy set.
When you scan from
left to right,
you look at the next object
module or the object file,
and all you have to do is
O goes to O union Fi dot O.
OK, this is the I'th
step of the algorithm.
OK, now we have to go
to the next step, which
is get to the defined symbols.
So as we go from
left to right, we
build up a set of
defined symbols.
Initially it's null, and
then we start with D1,
and then we do D1 union
D2, and all the way.
So up to the I'th step, what
we're going to end up with is
obviously at the I'th iteration,
we are going to have some
running set of defined
symbols that have been defined
in the modules so far.
And we're just going to do
D goes to D union Di where
Di is the set of symbols that
are defined in module number I.
OK, in the last set,
we're going to calculate,
and the linker is going
to calculate as a set U.
And U is the set of all
undefined symbols so far.
So you have a set of
undefined symbols.
And you are at the I'th stage
of this process where up to here
you have a set U of
undefined symbols.
And now you're seeing this
new module a bunch more
undefined symbols.
So clearly what you
have to do first
is do union Ui, correct, because
you now have built up a bigger
set of undefined symbols.
But then, notice that there
might be symbols that were
previously undefined that
are now being defined
in the I'th module, right?
Otherwise, I mean, if
this set kept growing,
then all you would
end up with is
a big undefined set at the end.
So clearly there are symbols
that are being defined
and subsequent modules.
So you have to
subtract out a set.
And the set you have
to subtract obviously
is the undefined
set intersection
whatever is being
defined in this module.
OK, and so the linker does
this from left to right.
It's actually a
pretty simple linker
because it doesn't go
back and do anything.
And it doesn't actually
have to at least
for this way of hooking
up object files together.
And what you get at the end are
three sets: O, D, and U, OK?
And, the linker outputs
success, it then
gets to the relocation
stage of U is null.
If there are no undefined
symbols at the end,
you know that now
you can then relocate
by modifying patching the
different addresses together
to produce your big program.
But if the set is
not null, you know
that no matter what
you do to relocate,
there is some symbol that
is not being defined,
which means that module won't
run, which means the program
won't run, OK?
So that's kind of what
this linking program does.
It just goes from left to
right and resolves all symbols.
And although it's done
in the context of,
we've discussed this in the
context of a particular example
of how GNU-Linux
does its linking,
the basic idea is the same.
Essentially, all
symbol resolution
will turn out to use some
variant of something that
greatly resembles this method.
There is actually
only one problem
with what I described
so far, and it's wrong.
So, what's the problem?
Yeah?
Right.
If the symbol is undefined
in F1 and defined in F2,
you're fine because
let's take this example.
I had M dots it's OK.
We're just building up sets.
So you can have a
symbol that's defined.
You are saying,
what if the symbol
is defined in one of the files
and undefined in the next file?
No, it doesn't matter for this.
It's going to matter when we
talk about something called
a library, but it's not
going to matter here
because we've built up these
sets of what are defined
and what are undefined?
So let's say you defined a
symbol here, and you come here
and you find that it
references a symbol that's
not locally defined, but has
been previously defined, right?
That's been built
up in the set, D.
So, in the end --
Oh I see, so the code
is a little wrong
because I have to
actually update.
You're right.
I had to modify that U line.
This is wrong.
Good.
So I have to modify the
set of undefined symbols
to include the things that
were previously defined.
So actually it should probably
have been U intersection D.
And that will probably fix it.
Good.
Any other errors?
Yeah?
Right.
So, there were two.
This one I actually
didn't realize.
But it's actually right.
So it should be
U intersection D.
The other one is
that we just keep
doing D goes to D union Di.
But now, if I define
a function, SQR here,
and I define the same
function SQR again here,
we're not going to know
which SQR to actually use.
So we have a duplicate symbol.
And so, in fact, what
the algorithm actually
ought to do is while it's
doing this union computation,
it better make sure
that any symbol that's
being defined in a
subsequent module
has not already been defined
in a previous module.
And, if there is a
duplicate definition,
it'll tell you that there's
a duplicate definition.
And I'm not going to
show you an example,
but if you just go and type out
a little -- use SQR twice --
and you run the compiler, GCC,
on it what you'll find is that
it'll tell you that this
symbol is multiply defined.
OK, so we're not going
to want that either.
So once you obtain
these different sets,
what you'll end up with
is information that
will tell the linker
everything about all
of the different symbols, and
where they have been defined,
and in which object file
they've been defined.
And so, the step that
it has to do after that
is the relocation step.
So this was the first step.
It will turn out that this step
is also pretty straightforward
because what happens when
GCC runs on a single C file
and produces a
single dot O file is
it contains in it information
on how to relocate
all of the variables
and all of the functions
that are defined in that module.
And there is a section
of the object file
that I haven't shown you called
the relocation section that
tells you, for any given
variable in the text,
or any given line of
code in the text area,
all of the load instructions
and all of the variables, how
they get remapped inside.
So that's maintained.
Basically the approach is
to maintain local table.
And, it's called the relocation
section of your program, OK?
So, we're going to get to
loading in a little bit.
But before we get to
loading, I want to get back
to symbol resolution.
So here we just talked about
taking a bunch of dot O files
and producing a final program.
But there is another notion
of something called a library.
So, how you do symbol
resolution with a library?
So an example of a library
here is lib C dot A, which
is the standard C library.
And that's the
library that contains
the definition of printf.
So if you use printf or any of
these other standard functions,
they define the C library.
Another example is
the math library,
where you have the
square root function
and a bunch of other
mathematical functions.
So we are going to
want to know how
to resolve with the library.
So first, we have to
know what a library is.
And what a library
is, is just you
take a bunch of object files
together and basically just
concatenate them together.
It's not literally concatenation
because the library also
maintains an index that
says, has information
about what modules,
what included
dot O files contain
which symbol definitions?
But essentially it's
just a concatenation
of a bunch of dot O files, OK?
And they get put
together in a library.
And there is some index
information in front
that says what is where
inside the library.
OK, so the approach to
resolving symbols with a library
is almost the same as
what we have so far,
except with one twist.
And the twist is
that often libraries
are extremely big, much bigger
than a single dot O file.
And, one approach to
resolving with libraries
would be to apply the
same approach here.
So when you have
something that's
defined in the standard C
library like lib C or the math
library like lib
L, you could just
include the entire text
of the library inside
to build your program.
But that just makes
things extremely bloated.
I mean, think about
if you just wanted
to use printf in your program
like we had in this example
and you had to include the
entire C library, which
is megabytes long, it
seems like not a good way
of doing the linking.
So what we're going to do with
the resolution of libraries
is essentially the idea is
to only include the dot O
files that are in the library
in which undefined symbols that
were previously
encountered are defined.
And if you think a little
bit about what I said,
that's one reason why
it usually a good idea
when you do GCC and
use the linker, use LD,
to specify the
libraries at the end
because what we're
going to do is
we're going to take
all the dot O files,
and then they're going to
be things like dash LM.
I mean, the standard
C library is usually,
by default, already included
on the command line.
But if you have functions
like square root and so on,
here it what we're going to
do is we're going to build up.
What the linker
is going to do is
it is going to build up a
set of undefined symbols
until it gets to the end.
And there's going to be
undefined symbols remaining.
If you use the
square root program,
the square root
function, and you
didn't write your own
square root function,
it's in the math library.
Then you might ask for the
math library to be included,
and you want to pull the
definition of square root
from The math library the
way in which the linker does
to pull the right dot O file is
that the math library is going
to have information that says
which object file contains what
symbols, and anytime you see an
undefined symbol at this stage,
we are going to scan
this archive looking
for the symbol that's been
undefined, in particular
looking at this example
for the square root symbol.
OK, and when we find the square
root symbol somewhere inside
in some dot O file, we're
going to take that dot O file,
and not the rest of
the library, and then
use this algorithm that we did.
So take that dot O file
alone and push that as input
to this algorithm.
That's the way in which
we're going to build it up.
So that's why at least in
this particular implementation
of the linker which is very
simple, if you put the LM
way up in front, you are
a little bit in trouble
because if Fn dot O is the file
that actually uses square root,
and the math library was
included well in front,
then square root
would not yet have
been part of the undefined
set of symbols until then.
And there are other
ways to deal with it.
You can have linkers that go
in more passes that presumably
can deal with this problem.
But this is just an example
of how GNU-Linux does this,
and that's just worth knowing.
So this idea of linking
and symbol resolution
and relocation,
people have worked
on this for a very long time.
And almost every
software system uses it.
In fact, if you use LaTeX to
build your design papers and so
on, it does symbol
resolution as well
because there is all
sorts of cross-references
that are there in LaTeX.
And it uses essentially the
same kinds of algorithms,
go over the files and
go over the documents
in multiple passes and
resolve the symbol.
So it's a pretty
general algorithm
that we described here of
building these different sets
to ultimately figure out whether
there are undefined references
remaining at the end or not.
So I want to step
back for a minute
and generalize on the
different approaches
that we've seen so far for
doing symbol resolution.
And today we saw one approach
for doing symbol resolution.
But in fact, last time we saw a
couple of different approaches
to resolve names whose values
we didn't actually know.
So, we're going to step
back and generalize
with a couple of
different techniques
that we saw the
different examples.
So the general problem
here, the specifics
are how you can find out where
these undefined symbols are
defined, or in the
UNIX example, how
you can take a big path name and
identify which blocks contain
the files or contain the
data for the file that
was named in the path.
But the general problem is
you have a set of names.
And associated with
each name is a value.
And these names get
associated with or mapped
to the different values.
In fact, the names get bound
And in this example,
the linker needed
to take a name like the
definition of a symbol
and needed to identify,
what's the value associated
with that symbol?
The value here in
this context is,
where is this name, the
square root function?
Where is it actually defined?
At what location is it?
OK, and so the way in
which that resolution
is going to be done is done
and general using something
called the name
mapping algorithm.
And the mapping of a name to
value being done by the name
mapping algorithm
takes into account,
or takes as input something
called the context.
And I'll describe this with
an example in a minute.
So somebody has found
a name to value.
And when you are
a linker or when
you are part of the
UNIX file system,
and you're trying to
identify the value associated
with the name, you're going
to have to resolve that name
to find a value.
And that resolution
is going to be
done in a particular context.
So, for example, you
might have two files
with the same name in two
different directories,
and that's fine.
The same name can have
two different values
because that resolution from
the name to the correct value,
in the directory case
it's an inode number would
be done in the context
of the directory in which
the resolution is being done.
OK, so what we've seen over
the last couple of days,
the last lecture, and today,
are three different ways
of doing it.
And it turns out that
in almost every system,
or in every system
that I know of, anyway,
there's basically three ways
of doing this name resolution.
The first way -- the simplest
way -- is a symbol lookup.
Look in the context
of a dot O file, which
has a set of defined symbols.
Taking one of the symbols,
the name, in that case,
as input, and finding
out where it's
been defined in that dot O file
is basically a table lookup.
That's what that symbol
table section describes.
From the disk example
from last time,
the inode table is an
example of a table lookup.
I mean, there's
a portion of disk
that has in it the mapping
between inode numbers
and the corresponding inodes.
And that's just a table lookup.
So when you want to go from
an inode number to an inode,
you do a table lookup.
And that's the
simplest base form,
base case of how this
name resolution is done.
The second way of
doing name resolution
is something called a
pathname resolution.
We didn't see an
example of this today,
but we saw an example
of pathname resolution
the last time.
If you take a big UNIX
pathname slash home
slash foo slash
bar, what we did was
start left to right
along that path
and narrowed down our resolution
of the file to get to the block
that we wanted while going
through a path, sorry, not
a search path, but going to
the path that names the item.
And a third way of
doing name resolution
is what we saw today.
And that's an example of
searching through contexts.
There's really no path here.
I just tell you, here's
a set of dot O files,
and here's a set of libraries.
And the symbols
that are undefined
are defined in different
modules of my program,
or F.O2 in different
modules of my program
are defined somewhere
among these modules.
And I'm not really going
to tell the linker what's
been defined where.
It's up to the linker
to figure it out,
and it does that by
basically running a search
running a search through a
variety of different contexts.
So, each dot O file
and each library
is a new context in which a
search for previously undefined
symbol happens.
And in this particular case,
the search within each context
takes the form of
the table lookup, OK?
So, those are the
three techniques
for how you do name
resolution in general.
And we saw two of
them today, and we
saw two of them, the
first two, last time
when we talked about
the UNIX file system.
So the last step in the
process of what a linker does
after symbol resolution
and relocation, relocation
in this particular kind of
linking, I didn't use the term,
but this form of
linking is called static
linking because we're
going to take all
of these different object files
and defined on the command line
or on the library,
and build together
a single big binary that has
been linked once up front where
the linker's called.
That's called static linking.
Internal relocation
in that context
is pretty straightforward.
But so we're not going to
talk more about that except
to note that this
relocation table is
maintained in each object file.
But the third step is a little
more slightly more complicated,
and actually varies a lot
depending on the system.
And that's program loading.
And the problem that's
solved by loading
is that the linker
produces an output
program that's executable.
It's and you can run a program.
In UNIX, you run it by typing
something on a command line.
Or in Windows, you
click on something,
and effectively that causes
a shell to execute a program.
So somebody has to
do the work of when
you type something on the
command line, somebody
has to do the work of looking
at what file has been typed,
taking the contents of
the file, loading it up
into memory, passing
control to something
that can then start
running the program.
And typically the place
where that control is passed
is the interpreter
corresponding to the program.
So all of this work
is done in UNIX
by a program called execve.
So the actual loader in UNIX
is a program called execve.
And its job, once you type
it on the command line,
is the shell invokes it.
And what it does is to do what I
said, which is look at the file
name, take the contents of
it, load it up into memory,
and pass control to basically
the first line of the program.
Often, modern object files
are a little more complicated.
They actually have
something that
says who the interpreter
of the program is.
So you pass control
to that interpreter,
which in turn goes
to a bunch of steps,
and then invokes the
first line in main.
And that's what the C
loader, the way in which
loading a program that's
written in C works.
So, so far what we've
seen is, as I mentioned,
an example of linking called
static linking where you take
all these object
files and libraries,
and extract the right
object files out of it
and build a big program.
So, what you'll find is
that even small programs
like this one, all it's doing
is multiplying two numbers.
If I compile it --
-- it's pretty
big, almost 400 kB.
I mean, it's
multiplying two numbers
and it takes 400
kB to multiply it.
And the reason is that
I made the mistake
of including, I have to
show the output to the user,
so I call it printf.
And printf happens with part
of a big object file that
defines a lot of other things.
And that whole thing got
built as part of the program.
Now, if you have
a lot of programs,
so it's not just that
the files are big.
I mean, disks, as a mentioned
a couple lectures ago,
disks are cheap.
And so that's not really
the problem as much.
The problem is that this
is the entire program,
so it has to get loaded in.
So if you have some machine on
which a hundred processors run,
and each of those
processors has printf's
in a few places or even one
printf, each of those programs
is going to be extremely big.
So the way in which you
deal with this problem
is to do something that's
pretty obvious in retrospect.
Why have multiple copies
of the same module?
Why don't we just have one copy
of that module running and all
the programs that
use that module?
And that's done using
an idea called a shared
object or shared modules.
And this stuff is extremely hot.
If you look at recent
activity in almost every
modular software system
like you look at Apache
or you look at many
database systems,
and also you look at GNU-Linux,
there's been a ton of activity
over the past five or six
years on different ways
of optimizing things so that,
the idea is a very old idea.
But there's still
been a lot of activity
making it efficient
and practical
over the last five to ten years.
The problem with shared
objects is the following.
And this has become
a little more clear
when we talk about actually
something called an address
space a couple
lectures from now.
But the basic problem is that
instructions are associated
with memory locations,
and they run
each thing in the object file.
And the binary has an
instruction location.
And data has a
particular location
associated with it as well.
And the problem is that when
you have two programs that each
want to use a shared module,
unless you're really careful
about how you design it, it's
going to be very hard for you
to ensure that for
both of those programs,
this module that's going to
be shared has exactly the same
addresses because if you have
in one program the module being
called from address 17, and in
another program the module is
written up as 255, then that
object cannot be shared, right?
It's two different objects.
And that's what happens
with static linking.
If you take the
SQR.O module and you
include that in two
different programs,
the addresses that get
associated with it in the two
different programs are going
to be completely different.
So one challenge, and a
significant one in the shared
object is objects
that are shared
by different programs
running at the same time is
to generate code that is what
is called position independent.
So it doesn't have
in it anything
that's different for
the different programs.
And so this is called
position independent code.
So the idea is when
you call the module
on your computer,
the program counter
is going to point to something.
And all of the addresses
inside that module
are going to have addresses.
Obviously, they're
going to have addresses,
but they're going to be
relative to the program counter.
So when you jump to a location,
I'm going to jump to 317.
You're going to
jump to something
that says five locations
from where you are now.
So it's a kind of addressing
called PC relative addressing.
And that's not going to be
the only thing that's used.
But by and large, a requirement
for position independent code
is that all of the addressing
be relative to, say,
the program counter.
And once you have this kind of
position independent code, what
you have to do in your program,
if you're using something
like the square root
program, let's say,
OK, in the math library
when you do the linking,
you don't have to include
the object file in which
square root is defined.
All that your object
file has to do now
is at the time it
was linked, there
is some library,
runtime library,
that you know when you
link the program has
the definition of square root.
So what the program
contains when
you run this F1 dot O, F2 dot O,
all the way through the library
is it's just going to maintain
a pointer, a name actually.
It's going to maintain a
name to where the square root
function is defined.
It's going to be a filename.
OK, and so this is why sometimes
when you type in a program,
and somebody has changed the
configuration on your machine
and built before, and somebody
changes the configuration,
sometimes you get an error
message that while you're
running the program, you get
an error message that says
some library dot SO not found.
It worked two days ago.
It doesn't work now.
And the reason for
that is somebody
may have moved things
around and you get an error
not when you
compile the program,
but when you run the program.
And many executions of
program may not actually
trigger the error at all.
It may get triggered only when
the actual object is needed.
And that's called
dynamic linking.
And again, the way in
which we do dynamic linking
is to use the same
name and constants.
Rather than embed the entire
object file corresponding
to the module corresponding
to a name of a function that's
being defined elsewhere,
maintain a reference to it.
And load that reference
up at runtime.
Now, in order to
enable for that object
to be shared between
different programs,
all of the addressing inside
that has to be relative.
That is, it has to be
independent of what
the PC's value for the starting
point of that module is.
And that's called
position independent code.
So that's the basic
story behind how
linking works and almost
all software systems
involving libraries and modules
ends up having a linking in it.
I mentioned LaTeX as
an example before.
Even document systems
have linking in it.
And it's a pretty fundamental
algorithm that we talked about.
It's specific to GNU-Linux,
but the basic idea
is pretty common.
Now, what we'll see next time
is that this way of modularizing
has a lot of nice
properties, allows
you to build big programs,
but at the same time
has pretty bad fault isolation
properties that we'll
talk about next time.